me llamo javier marcos y como veis soy
un soldado
lo primero que aprendí cuando ingresé en
la academia militar y de eso hace ya más
de 33 años es que uno solo no llega a
ningún sitio
que no es posible alcanzar un objetivo o
llegar a cualquier meta sin la ayuda de
los demás especialmente sin la ayuda de
determinadas personas que hacen que
despleguemos todo nuestro potencial que
nos inspiran a ser mejores que nos
inspiran a crecer a hacer muchas más
cosas de las que debemos hacer
estaréis conmigo en que hoy hacen falta
muchos hombres y mujeres así personas a
las que llamamos
pero a qué líderes me refiero
a los grandes líderes mediáticos famosos
poderosos bien posicionados en las
organizaciones
a los pequeños líderes del diaria
silenciosos esos que conocemos en los
hospitales en las fábricas en las aulas
en los comercios en las empresas en las
fuerzas armadas en las familias
me refiero a estos últimos porque ellos
los pequeños líderes que desde ahora voy
a llamar pequeños grandes líderes lo son
porque son el verdadero motor de la
sociedad
porque son los que hacen que la gente
sencilla haga grandes cosas
y propósito durante los próximos minutos
es invitaros a hacer un viaje interior
para llegar a dos conclusiones la
primera es que necesitamos muchos
pequeños grandes líderes
y la segunda que sepáis fruto de mi
experiencia
qué cualidades pueden hacer de
cualquiera de vosotros un pequeño gran
líder
y para eso me voy a servir de un ejemplo
real de un hecho que sucedió hace muy
poco a un grupo de soldados a un grupo
de nuestros soldados
7 de marzo 2012
jose moreno ramos sargento de la legión
se encuentra al frente de sus caballeros
y damas legionarios en afganistán en la
provincia de badghis y su misión es
asegurar un sector de una ruta conocida
como la ruta lithium por la cual
circulaba la mayoría de la ayuda
humanitaria que entregábamos al pueblo
afgano
cuando está cumpliendo esa misión
comienzan a recibir fuego directo
uno de esos disparos alcanza en el
cuello a uno de sus legionarios
iván castro
moreno su sargento se da cuenta
rápidamente
organiza la defensa comprueba que todos
reaccionan bien y sin pensarlo dos veces
abandona su puesto de tirador
y se lanza a por castro que está a 40
metros no hay otra forma de hacerlo
reptando se está jugando la vida pero no
lo duda
comienza a reptar ante la sombra de sus
compañeros llega a su posición
la herida es grave
castro está sangrando abundantemente
moreno le dice tienes que venir conmigo
castro le dice mi sargento vuelva a su
puesto
yo puedo continuar
el sargento le dice tu hija van a hacer
en dos semanas tienes que verla
el cabo castro le dice no se preocupe mi
sargento primero tengo que cumplir esta
misión
pero bueno lo que quiere dejar solo
insiste le corta la hemorragia
lo carga a la espalda y comienza a
recorrer
todo ese camino que había recorrido
anteriormente bajo el fuego enemigo
para llevarle a un lugar seguro
el resto de la sección
le protege a uno y a otro les cubre
consiguen llegar al puesto de tirador
consiguen rechazar el ataque
cuando la situación se tranquiliza
un helicóptero evacua a castró a un
hospital de campaña
los médicos preguntan quién es la
persona que ha atendido al cabo
y aseguran que quien lo hubiera hecho le
había salvado la vida
os imaginais el impacto del
comportamiento del jefe de pelotón en
sus soldados
como explicase este comportamiento
porque era su deber
sólo por eso no
en morir no había algo más había valores
claro que su preparación intelectual era
muy buena y su preparación técnica fue
cada punk a reptar bajo el fuego fue
capaz de curarle y regresar su
preparación física está fuera de toda
duda pero su verdadera fuerza le vino
del interior de su interior hoy
precisamente esta es mi responsabilidad
formar pequeños grandes líderes
en las academias militares igual que en
esta universidad
se imparten conocimientos se hacen
prácticas pero sabéis que es lo más
importante que les enseñamos
a descubrir su enorme potencial interior
cuando descubren sus valores
cuando descubren su grandeza interior y
lo ponen en práctica están en el camino
del liderazgo porque serlo está al
alcance de cualquiera es una decisión
personal no cuesta dinero
cuesta tiempo cuesta esfuerzo cuesta
determinación y cuesta voluntad
y sobre todo cuesta renunciar al ego que
muchas veces puede más que nuestra
conciencia
cuesta renunciar al interés personal en
beneficio de algo intangible y que por
lo tanto hoy no está de moda que es el
bien de los demás el bien del equipo
seguro que si pregunto a cada uno de
vosotros
cuál sería la lista ideal de ese líder
de ese pequeño gran líder habría muchas
listas yo me gustaría compartir con
vosotros cinco que no deben faltar en
ninguna de esas listas
la primera la integridad que es la
integridad muy fácil es el lugar donde
nuestras palabras y nuestras acciones se
encuentran si no soy íntegro nadie me va
a creer no seré creíble
seré un hipócrita aquí no hay niveles
intermedios o se es íntegro o se es
hipócrita
si no soy íntegro se van a dar cuenta
los que están alrededor
y que ocurrirá
que no creerán en mí no confiaran en mí
la confianza confiar en vosotros confiar
en vuestras capacidades sino confío en
mí como voy a inspirar confianza a los
demás
si no me gana la confianza de mis
soldados podría ser su jefe podría
ordenarle que hagan cosas y las van a
hacer porque soy su jefe podría disponer
de su tiempo de su fortaleza física
porque tengo el poder que me da la ley o
la organización
puede ser su jefe pero no su líder sin
embargo si tengo su confianza además
podría disponer de su entusiasmo de su
lealtad
tendré la autoridad que ellos me dan la
autoridad que viene de abajo no el poder
que viene de arriba la autoridad que
ellos me han dado
la ejemplaridad
tengo que lograr que mi comportamiento
sirva de referencia para los demás y que
sea un comportamiento positivo que anime
que empuje a los demás
cada día a mis alumnos les insisto dos
cosas la primera que debe ser ejemplar
es en todo momento volvemos a decir lo
mismo aquí no hay niveles intermedios de
ejemplaridad o eres ejemplar o no lo
eres hay que serlo en todo momento no
sólo cuando es fácil o cuando nos
interesa hay que ser ejemplar en todo
momento y la segunda que tengan presente
que la palabra convence
pero el ejemplo arrastra
quienes están a nuestro alrededor nunca
van a recordar lo que hemos dicho van a
recordar lo que hayamos hecho
si somos íntegros creíbles ejemplares
estamos por buen camino
porque estaremos en condiciones
de influir
qué es de lo que se trata
pero ojo hay dos formas de influir en el
comportamiento humano puedes inspirar
o puedes manipular dicho de otra manera
puedo servir a los demás inspirar o
servirme de los demás manipular depende
de vosotros
fijaros moreno fue íntegro
fue creíble generó confianza fue
ejemplar
supo gestionar la incertidumbre hoy está
muy de moda hablar de riesgos nos han
educado para afrontar riesgos pero que
poco hemos aprendido para gestionar la
incertidumbre moreno fue también capaz
de gestionar
la incertidumbre y todo eso para qué
para inspirarles a los suyos para
contagiarles el que valor el valor es el
valor por antonomasia el primero de los
valores el valor porque es la puerta que
abre a los demás valores teo que tener
valor para ser íntegro valor para ser
ejemplar
valor para ser creíble
si soy así no solo me voy a ganar el
entusiasmo la lealtad de los míos me voy
a ganar su corazón
y el corazón per donde residen las
fortalezas importantes que tenemos es la
puerta que nos va a permitir actuar así
si practicas estos valores seréis unos
pequeños grandes líderes porque hoy el
que es líder ya no depende como la
antigüedad de su fortaleza física ya no
depende de su capacidad intelectual
claro que es importante la competencia
profesional claro que tenemos que ser
muy buenos en lo nuestro pero a mí me
parece que esto de los headhunters va a
menos
creo que lo más importante ahora son los
head hunters
porque el líder actual crece en los
corazones vive de las emociones
conecta con las emociones de vuestra
gente
es el vínculo más fuerte que existe
y no me puedo dejar la humildad
la humildad que no es pensar que uno
vale menos
es pensar menos en uno
no es infravalorarse eso no es ser
humilde no es pensar menos en que uno
vale menos no es creer que uno vale
menos no es comparar ni decir no yo soy
peor es pensar menos en uno y que
difícil porque entre todas cuando uno es
humilde los demás no se dan cuenta y
siempre nos gusta el reconocimiento no
penséis en eso sabéis dónde viene la
palabra humilde
bueno viene del latín del latín hummus y
que significa humus
es la capa más fértil de la tierra
es la tierra que fertiliza al resto de
la tierra
no es casualidad el que es humilde
enriquece a los demás
si sois humildes si somos humildes nada
nos puede dañar ni los elogios ni las
críticas porque sabemos lo que somos y
estaréis conmigo en que cuando uno
ejerce el liderazgo con humildad es
mucho más fácil seguirle sin esfuerzo
de verdad os digo que una de las
contribuciones más importantes que
hacemos en las academias militares a la
sociedad
es formar pequeños grandes líderes que
están a nuestro servicio para velar por
vuestro bienestar por vuestros derechos
por vuestra libertad por esta seguridad
los invito a esta reflexión
voy a concluir
pero antes me gustaría animaros a
practicar estos valores
y a contagiar a los demás estos valores
porque los valores son lo que hacen
grandes a las personas es lo que va a
hacer grandes es lo que os va a
convertir en pequeños grandes líderes
como decía capaces de hacer que la
sociedad se mueva en la dirección
correcta y capaces de contagiar a las
gentes sencillas para que antes hagan
grandes cosas si creéis en estos valores
y los prácticas ya sois unos pequeños
grandes líderes porque no hay súper
hombres no os engañéis ni súper mujeres
hay súper voluntades
creer en vosotros tener la voluntad de
serlo
mirad
hay quien dice que una de las armas yo
lo digo yo aunque sé de armamento que
una de las armas más potentes para
cambiar el mundo
es la educación
yo estoy de acuerdo yo sigo queriendo
cambiar el mundo y creo que una buena
forma de hacerlo es educando a ser
pequeños grandes líderes muchas gracias
[Aplausos]